bonjour alexandre langlois merci de me
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
mission d'information sénatoriale cet
après midi qu'est ce que vous espérez
entendre de la bouche de christophe
castaner bon à l'entraînement tente des
vérités ou éventuellement sa démission
mais pour le moment pour avoir écouté le
débit de sion d'audition on est dans le
mensonge le mensonge surtout ce qu'il a
annoncé
il a fait un bilan de glorifier le bilan
de son mandat alors que finalement il ya
rien à glorifier il ajuste truqués des
chiffres je donne un exemple il a
commencé par ça en disant que tu aurais
dix mille policiers de plus sur le
quinquennat alors que les deux premières
années déjà il ya 500 postes qui n'ont
pas été pourvus faute d'avoir un niveau
de recrutement assez au rapport aux gens
qui veulent passer le concours et après
ça continue il dit qu'il va augmenter le
budget alors que le budget 2020 est à la
baisse
il dit que le budget formation va être à
la hausse alors qu'il est déjà la baisse
cette année il a encore à la baisse des
prochaines donc on a en face devant un
mauvais joueur de poker dont le mieux
c'est qu'il s'en aille
vous avez donc à la démission de
christophe castaner le 8 juin dernier
vous avez envoyé une lettre ouverte à
emmanuel macron concernant le racisme
dans la police voulzy brossé un tableau
un peu glorieux et vous écrivez je cite
que l'inaction de christophe castaner tu
qu'elle serait donc les bonnes mesures
les bonnes réformes à mener au sein de
la police c'est ça qui était si audio
s'il a bien parlé du suicide de nos
collègues devant la commission
sénatoriale précieux faire pleurer dans
les chaumières mais il n'a rien fait
pour apporter des solutions à cela il ya
juste continuer de compter les morts
c'est quand même catastrophique qu'on
est ministre de l'intérieur il a
d'ailleurs bien reconnu que c'était un
problème structurel de la police
nationale donc en fait faut faire
quelque chose alors des choses de ce
qu'on a vu il ya nos collègues québécois
qui avait le même problème de suicides
de que nous dans les années 80
aujourd'hui l'on résorbé
avec un taux de suicide comme conforme à
la population par exemple avec un suivi
psychologique obligatoire pour tous les
fonctionnaires
aujourd'hui quand un fonctionnaire va
voir un psychologue et découragé d'y
aller s'il y va il passe pour un faible
il fait partie de moqueries donc en fait
c'est contre-productif donc si tout le
monde y va de façon obligatoire déjà ça
permet de d'aider ceux qui sont en
souffrance et des fois de déceler en
amont des personnes qui pourraient avoir
des fragilités
donc ça ce serait une première chose à
deuxième chose d'avoir des sticks de
travail compatibles avec une vie de
famille et vie privée équilibré donc
monsieur castaner l'a également dit
grâce à lui on a voté un nouveau cycle
de travail qui permet d'avoir un
week-end sur deux à mercredi sur deux
effectivement ça a été voté par contre
ce n'est pas appliquée dans les faits
donc en fait on est dans la poudre de
perlin papa ce qui fait que nos
collègues continuent d'avoir un week end
sur 6 1 mercredi sur six donc aussi
avoir cet équilibre après des missions
qui peuvent être difficiles voire se
ressourcer avec des amis ou la famille
se serait nécessaire et a priori le
ministre ne l'a pas compris enfin ils
ont carrément budgété les heures
supplémentaires de policiers souffrent
d'avoir des heures supplémentaires à
outrance il s'est vanté d'avoir payé des
heures supplémentaires les moins chers
que leur normale ce qui est déjà une
honte
once d'espoir payé moins cher que
d'autres normales il les a budgété pour
l'année prochaine plutôt que de budgéter
des heures supplémentaires ce qui veut
dire qu'on sait qu'il va avoir besoin de
renforts
renforçant des policiers mais tire de
monde sur le terrain et arrêtons de
mettre de diriger la police n'importe
comment comme c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle donc là alexandre langlois vous
venez de nous proposer certaines
réformes pour pour la police mais
concernant les cas de racisme dans la
police on a eu des exemples au sein des
forces de l'ordre qu'on pourrait
s'appeler policiers de rouen la page
facebook révélée par streetpress comment
lutter contre ce phénomène
tout en ménageant les syndicats de
police ils étaient nombreux à manifester
ces dernières semaines est ce que c'est
un exercice de communication période
pour pour christophe castaner qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
je pense déjà si les bénéfices t54
police manifestent dans la rue c'est
avec la corde christophe castaner en
fait on est face à un jeu de dupes pour
fait tout simplement je rappelle que
coillot le mouvement spontané des
policiers en colère en 2016 quand nos
collègues ont été brûlés à
viry-châtillon donc une vraie motif est
une vraie cause salariale les policiers
n'ont jamais pu atteindre place beauvau
ni l'elysée ni étaient encadrés par des
gendarmes qui nous ont bloqué la route
si les policiers les syndicats de police
ont pu arriver jusque devant place
beauvau c'est que c'est orchestré par
place beauvau le deuxième chose quand
monsieur l'allemand le préfet de police
déclare à l'assemblée nationale hier que
pourquoi ils tolèrent des manifestations
illégales du policier c'est parce qu'il
ne connaît pas les responsables je veux
dire landais dans le foutage de gueule
complexe les responsables sont
clairement identifiés qui sont sur place
et les responsables syndicaux
donc tant qu'on fera la chasse aux
sorcières au lanceur dallas dans la
police nationale par exemple sur le
racisme doit manoir a été long mais a
proposé une exclusion temporaire de
fonction de 18 mois ferme et six avec
sursis supplémentaire parce qu'il a
dénoncé des actes racistes
commençons par condamner plutôt ce
compromis les actes racistes plutôt que
lancèrent dallaire parce que la logique
de l'administration c'est c'est vous qui
avez sali l'image de la police nationale
parce que ça s'est su à l'extérieur et
quand leur réponse si vous aviez fait
votre travail ça ne se serait pas su à
l'extérieur ils lui disent ouais mais
c'est pas notre problème donc voila et
je rappelle que dans la police le
racisme qu en 2012 à nos collègues
antillais s'est suicidé parce qu'il se
faisait traiter de par son
commandant de crs la sanction
administrative de ce commandant
s'arrêter sais pas
repas recommencer donc tant que le
problème ne sera pas gérer parce que
nous avons des carriéristes au dessus
qui ne veulent pas de la caisse qui
défraye aussi des personnes dans la
hiérarchie qui sont un raciste un
ministre qui veut rien faire et qui
cautionnent ces agissements ça
n'avancera pas et le noeud du problème
reste également l'inspection générale de
la police nationale qui est sous tutelle
du ministre et qui n'ira jamais contre
les gens qui m'ont mis en place et une
grosse différence par exemple avec la
contrôle de la pollution d'angleterre
ils ont aussi un hit dans l'eure dans
leur nom mais ça veut dire indépendant
et par inspection je crois que ça fait
toute la différence
on a entendu notre reporter l'île afin
amouzou parler du de l'étranglent de la
clé d'étranglement il doit revenir là
dessus notamment aujourd'hui christophe
castaner après une volte-face on sait
que le père de cédric joue via sur notre
antenne a demandé à interdire la clé
d'étranglement quelle est votre position
une fois de plus on est chez les clowns
c'est dire que monsieur castaner a dit
que ce serait interdite il interdisait
tout de suite mais que sous cas
particulier on continuerait de le faire
donc finalement il a rétropédalé pour
dire que ce ne serait plus enseigner on
sait déjà pu lancer en gendarmerie ni
dans la pénitentiaire mais encore dans
la police il a dit c'est dangereux on va
continuer de l'utiliser quand même donc
soit c'est dangereux on arrête tout de
suite soit c'est pas dangereux quand tu
es d'utiliser on ne part non on demande
la formation par exemple comment des
techniques de judo d'immobilisation mais
bien sûr ça ça demande de la formation
continue sa demande des crédits sa
demande du budget et ça le ministère n'a
pas envie de rater un sou parce que
peut-être cyniquement peut-être je pose
la question paraît que monsieur castaner
ils répondent ça coûte moins cher
d'indemniser une famille endeuillée
plutôt que de former des policiers
quotidiennement dernière question alex
langlois assa traoré 1 la third adama
traoré ces jeunes décédés en 2016 puis
une intervention controversée des forces
de l'ordre va recevoir un prix aux états
unis pour sa lutte contre les violences
policières qu'est ce que ça vous évoque
déjà c'est les états unis donc on fait
les états unis font bien ce qu'ils
veulent en france ça ne choquerait un
petit peu parce qu'il ya tout est
mélangé dans ce combat par exemple
notamment cédé gendarmes en fait et les
gendarmes ont un code militaire n'ont
pas les mêmes techniques d'intervention
donc en faisant un combat fourre tout où
on mélange tout et on fait des amalgames
donc je pense que son combat est
complètement idéologique au final il ya
une volonté de vérité ça je peux le
comprendre ça c'est une faute de la
justice en fait on pour dire la lenteur
de la justice est inadmissible qu'au
bout de quatre ans ne connaissent
toujours pas la vie rick est ce qui
s'est passé par contre après son combat
en fait il ya un amalgame police
gendarmes tout ça donc on fait on n'y
comprend plus rien donc si les assiettes
unis veut lui remettre un prix tant
mieux la bonne nouvelle c'est que ce
n'est pas en france
merci alexandre l'angle
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général du syndicat vigie police il